whip time guys spiderworn back at it if
you guys watch yesterday's video i'll
have you guys know
he called me back he apologized from the
bottom of his heart he was incredibly
sorry and i said
this is your last
chance
warren to be my friend your last chance
and he said i'm only going to cover
spider-man videos for the rest of my
life even after this movie comes out and
i say good and we're going to react to
every single one of them that's what
friends do
that's a paraphrasing of what really
went down spider-man no way home trailer
to description leaked and run time
revealed i'm expecting another phone
call you have to check in with me weekly
that is part of the court agreement
[Music]
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we're going to be talking about
something that i know a lot of people
are going to be very very interested in
you may have heard about it going around
online but there is a supposed leaked
description for the second spider-man no
way home trailer the trailer that
everybody is waiting for there's always
a leak description
every single day why the trailer may not
have been released yet we're almost
within a month of the actual movies
release and we still haven't gotten an
official trailer for it so a lot of us
are wondering what the heck and to top
it all off we could have the run time
for spider-man no way home that could
have possibly been revealed then of
course i'll talk about all of this in
this video so a lot of good good posting
this online but take it with a grain of
salt because we really don't know if
this is true or not i will say i hope it
is because i believe this is how the
second trailer should be this was posted
anonymously online and the person says
the trailer is pretty much finished but
it's still being polished and it's in
the dubbing process right now and the
person says this is not the order of the
scenes in the actual trailer but these
are the scenes that are going to be in
the trailer there's a few scenes from
the first trailer and some are a bit
extended but we will see a shot of peter
at a courtroom but we mostly see his
face and we don't see matt murdock that
means while he's in the courtroom they
pretty much just focus on him and you
can't really see anybody else around
doesn't mean that matt murdock isn't in
the movie i doubt they would put that in
the trailers honest thought last night
before i went to bed i was imagining
that when we do see matt murdock in this
movie just the theater applauding and
and that made me so happy this little
fantasy of mine who made me so happy the
thought of people applauding to see
charlie cox back again can you imagine
if that happens at the premiere and then
people are applauding to see matt
murdock and then feige's there and he's
like yeah i guess we do got to bring
back that murder we gotta bring back
that charlie cox green light at disney
plus tonight and he goes on to say all
five villains are shown green goblin doc
ock electro sandman and the lizard and
these are pretty much the villains that
are confirmed to be in the film there is
not going to be a sixth villain
according to some insiders i know some
people are disappointed about that i am
too i just feel like you were so close
to the sinister six you probably should
have went for it but then again i do
have trust in marvel studios and since
they're kind of running the whole thing
here i'm sure it's going to be great i
really don't think we need a six villain
i i feel like we got enough like five is
plenty
there was never such a thing as the
sinister six i think we would all be
perfectly happy with the amount of
villains yeah exactly i think it's just
that a word association and then the
mental association to that fact who
knows i mean we could find out that
mysterio was involved in this still
behind the scenes so it could be a
surprise one man it's just so funny that
like they the thing that was confirmed
was jamie foxx i was like the first
thing that was confirmed and we still
haven't gotten an official image of him
yet going to show us a lot of doc ock a
lot of that scene with doc ock and
spidey on the bridge and it looks like
we're going to get even more of that in
the second trailer if this is true it
says some scenes from the alternate
first trailer are shown including a shot
with peter covered in green paint it
says peter fights electro now this is
interesting because i'm curious to see
if it's just peter kind of running away
from some lightning or if they actually
show jamie foxx as electro i mean they
showed out for molina
they showed a pumpkin bomb even though
they didn't show the green goblin it
would make sense that they would show
jamie foxx especially because in the
first trailer it didn't really show any
electro at all yes it did show some
lightning but if you're not super
hardcore fans like we are you don't
really know what to look for and you
don't really know that that's electro
and it does seem like this specific
second trailer is going to focus more on
introducing some villains and really
talking about the plot which i think is
going to be based off of everything that
i've heard peter parker letting the
villains loose and trying to fight them
and get them back into dr strange's
mystical magical prison so they can put
them back in their original dimension
universe reality whatever you want to
call it so if that's the main player it
would make sense that the second trailer
would focus on these villains that are
loose i mean i feel like at this point
with all that's been revealed you could
show the five villains and i think that
would just get people that much more
excited about it in fact leaning more
into that terrain if they choose not to
show toby and andrew in this trailer
would be just and probably perhaps
enough of an indicator for those who did
watch those prior films you know that's
like why i think focusing on green
goblin and doc gawk in the first trailer
was so exciting is because people
associate that with tobey maguire and
then you see the ones with andrew
garfield i feel like people who are not
as much in the loop as we have all been
with tracking this news is enough to let
them know that they're probably going to
show up in this movie i'm totally fine
with the secrecy in the marketing of the
actual promos that sony's doing because
you guys remember far from home they did
not bother to tell us like one bit that
mysterio was actually even though we all
knew they didn't bother to tell us once
in the trailers that he's actually a bad
guy in fact there's so much in the last
half of far from home that's just not in
the trailers and so i love the idea of
them doing that with no way home as well
would pretty much just keep it into the
first half that's become a big question
for me is with all this stuff that they
are choosing to show us and all these
things that are hinted at what are they
going to completely save just for the
movie that's going to blow all our minds
you know
well everything that's been leaked
that's true
this part says strange is shown a bit
more including a scene of ned
interacting with him i'm not really sure
how much doctor strange is going to be
involved with this film i think he's
going to play a big part in the
beginning but i think for the most part
it's going to be peter out there trying
to go get the villains but here's a big
rumor that i heard ned is actually going
to be the one to bring toby and andrew
to tom holland spider-man
he's not going to be responsible for
bringing them into the universe and to
the mcu but somehow he is the one that
manages to get the three of them to team
up that's just something i heard treat
it as a rumor for now interesting why
because neither toby or andrew had a guy
in the chair just to try and make ned
feel a little bit more useful yeah and
maybe try and motivate that hobgoblin
turn people keep expecting even though
that'll get even more confusing now you
have william defoe there's a shot of
peter all bloody in his far from home
suit that is probably the same battle as
that empire magazine photo and i would
assume since they are showing some other
villains in this trailer they'll
probably show peter all beat up the
trailers need to make it seem like peter
is way over his head with fighting all
of these villains and that he kind of
can't handle it and that he's going to
have to overcome something or meet up
with some other people in order to take
them on it then says there's a shot of
peter at feast we see the logo in the
background talking to somebody with a
worried look it doesn't show who he's
talking to though now i know when people
hear this most people will automatically
think miles morales and i really am
wondering if they will tease him in this
movie i mean after all he already does
exist in the mcu and the last thing that
was the tease was that andrew anderson
we are teased but not shown and i want
to talk about wait a minute
because this is apparently the reason
why we don't have the trailer yet marvel
studios and sony seem to be at a
disagreement on whether or not they
should show them in the trailer or not
according to the rumor kevin feige does
not want to show andrew garfield and
toby maguire in the trailer he wants
them to be revealed in the actual film
and not talk about them beforehand
however the rumor also says that sony
does want to show them sony wants money
they do want to tease them just a little
bit before the movie comes out and
according to this rumor this is why the
trailer has not been released yet
because they have not decided on whether
or not they're going to show the other
two spider-man in the trailer you guys
know how we feel i think just a little
bit of a tease is just fine just a tiny
bit of a tease you don't even have to
show their faces you could just allude
to the fact that there's other
spider-man with a specific type of
obscured shot or whatever enough to
indicate like yes there's other
spider-man in here but you don't have to
show their faces directly a-okay with
that but the last thing that i want to
talk about today is that the possible
run time for spiderman no way home could
have been revealed there's a very
popular portuguese website called
ingresso.com it's basically like
fandango.com and the twitter account
spiderman brazil noticed that spiderman
no way home was listed on the website
and when you click on spiderman away
home it gives a run time of two hours
and 39 minutes
two minutes
how long the movie is going to be and
that's pretty long it's not quite three
hours like avengers end game but it's
pretty dang long the eternals is 245 i
think and i thought that that was a
really good length so what i really want
to have for everybody
everyone agrees you think they should
show toby and andrew in this trailer or
not should they reveal them in a trailer
or revealed them in the theater let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below i think two hours
and 40 minutes is a fantastic run time
for all that they're trying to include
in this one package right here yeah i'm
all for it if it comes out even longer
then i'll opt for that too like i could
i could go for like an avengers end game
run time for something like this
especially when john watts is coming out
and saying that this is essentially
their like spider-man end game film make
it a longer movie two hours and 40
minutes that sounds like enough time for
some breathing room we only got a month
or so away and the trailer two is
probably going to come between november
15th and november 17th keep a lookout
guys subscribe to cosmic wonder if you
haven't done so already i am so excited
the spider-man hype train is so alive
we'll catch you guys soon